hey y'all intended couch here and in
this tighty tuesday video we're gonna be
going over
convolutional neural networks so
convolutional
neural net neural networks are very uh
popular among computer vision
and i think it's kind of the next um
step when you're learning
about neural networks and you're trying
to transition away from your
traditional densely connected layers
so a a convolutional neural network
really
is composed off of a
um a convolutional layer and a pulling
layer
so the convolutional layer is
essentially this sliding window
that's only seeing like a patch of
images or a patch of pixels
especially in the image context so this
is a
convolutional layer it's basically
trying to figure out
and apply some filters to extract some
type of features
so with images and especially the data
that we're going to be working on
uh the convolutional layer will try to
like detect edges
in the number or the handwritten digit
and we don't actually have to specify
how it extracts
the edges and features from the image
instead we
use neural networks to define and create
its own function so the next layer
that's
a part of a convolutional neural network
is a pooling layer
and the pulling layer essentially
extracts and summarizes
the results from a convolutional layer
um so that's pretty straightforward
after that we basically flatten the
layer because
when you take these convolutional
systems
it converts this data into a
dimensional object and we want to
flatten it so we can actually have an a
general output for the neural network to
activate on
so when you you basically just uh
summarize and reshape
the results from our convolutional and
max pooling layers and then we
just add your standard densely connected
layers um there's there's some more
images that i thought were interesting
i can kind of explain the convolutional
neural network
this one i think is a pretty good
summary of what it's doing
um this is just a two um there's two
convolutional layers with
two pooling layers a densely connected
layer and then the output
pretty straight forward um right here i
think kind of shows
i'm sorry this image isn't very um high
quality but it
shows the general idea where it has this
um convolutional part
uh and then shows the um
uh summarizations of it and also the
outputs of the actual feature
engineering from it
let's see and here's an actual
visualization of the convolutional
neural network's
outputs or activations and you can see
when it's looking at this digit
it's kind of looking at like the
straight lines the edges of the number
and then trying to use those as inputs
for our final model to predict
the the number class so let's actually
put this
into um into an actual r script so i'm
gonna go
to our studio uh load up in our markdown
file
i'm gonna call this tidy tuesday uh i'll
just say
conf okay i'm also recording this
on sunday i will be doing some more
pre-recorded videos
um today because i will i'm actually in
the middle of a move
so i won't have time to make um some of
these tiny tuesday videos
so um probably at the end of november
i'll
um be able to make more videos um
specifically based on your
feedback but the next few weeks i'm
going to have some pre-recorded
um content so i'm going to load in the
tidyverse and then uh
keras which is the neural network
framework that we like to use
or those i like to use okay
so with keras they actually have the
data sets already inside the package so
we can just download it
ourself so i'm just going to call this
the mnist
data frame and then i'll call in the
dataset
mnist okay and in this
mnist data frame is actually a
an object with other data frames we have
our input
images um our input
labels and then we can also do it for
the uh test sets so
so df uh test um images
um and then test uh labels
okay so i'm just gonna rename this to
like train images
uh train uh labels
and i'm gonna convert these to
categorical
because if we actually call in um the
labels
it just um essentially factors but when
we do it into categorical
it'll transfer it transform it to
essentially a one hot encoded vector
um so we'll just do that cool
i'm going to do that for the test images
and then the test labels
it's too categorical
oh dm text
oh test there we go
cool so if we look at our apple train
images we can see that it's essentially
the actual uh it's like a matrix
representation
of the actual image um
so we're gonna have to do some
conversions if we do a i think a summary
um we can see our max is 255 our min is
zero
and that's what uh that's how like
images specifically pixel data is
is uh shown if we do uh look at the
dimensions
there we have 60 000 images that are in
a 28 by 28 matrix
so we need to do some conversions
so let's actually convert these images
to essentially just a generic
um a vector so we can just say like
array reshape um our
images and then the dimensions which
will be
the amount of images
and then the actual um rows and columns
so that way it'll be more of a flattened
data set also what before i do that
i'm going to also uh normalize the
the uh the data so i'm gonna do some
in-max normalization
so let's first do the um
so let's actually just normalize it
using mid max normalization so training
images
divided by 255 test
images uh divided by 255
and then we can reshape our images so
that they're essentially
um not in us in a square format or a
matrix format but into your generic
um tabular format if we look at our
training images
you can see we have it in like a a
tabular format especially if we do like
our dimensions
so we have it like that cool
so now let's actually define our model
so we'll just say um
standard image model we'll say keras
model
sequential
and then in our standard image model
we're going to define
a dense layer um we'll say 512 units
our input shape will be this amount of
columns or features in our
train image and our activation
will be a rayleigh function
i will do that again
unc equals 512 activation
a railway and we'll just do that
one more time
and then for our final output our units
will be 10
because we have um 10 uh
so we do stu because we have 10 classes
that we want to predict
aka 0 through 9
of test.test labels we have uh
that is from zero through nine so we
need ten
outputs or ten nodes to act as the class
that we're trying to predict for the
probabilities
and since we're doing a multi-class
classification
we want to use a max function
okay so with our standard image model we
also want to
uh compile it and our optimizer
will be atom our loss will be
uh categorical
cross entropy oops i swell
i don't need that so categorical cross
entropy
and then our metrics will be accuracy
uh categorical cross plus
categorical cross entropy metrics is
oh i saw the optimizer wrong okay
so we have our generic um
you know dense layer model
right three layers so we're actually
gonna fit it
so we'll say fit our x will be
our train images our y will be train
labels our epics or epochs will be
50 our batch size will be
128 and we'll do a validation
split of 80 20
and we'll also enable callbacks where
we'll say callbacks
um early stopping and our patients will
be
um five so we're gonna train this
model this is essentially the hello
world for neural networks so
it's not too big of a deal and we should
get pretty high accuracy
we're gonna let that go and then we'll
start working on our
actual um convolutional neural network
and compare it to
your standard dense layer model to a
convolutional neural network
cool so we have that trained we're not
going to evaluate it yet
instead we're going to start building
our convolutional neural network
so with our original um
data set
um if we look at our dimensions for this
we have essentially
the image the raw image and for our
other
um imp our other train image we have it
um converted and with convolutional
neural networks we actually want to
preserve the image structure because um
the the actual convolutional layer is
going to go through the actual image
so if we go back here it's going to go
through the image
and since we converted this to a 784
column 784
column um
structure a convolutional neural network
wouldn't work on this converted
um image data set or this or on the
train image object
instead we actually have to use
the original structure but we have to do
some pre-processes
pre-processing to it so let's do that uh
our c
train images
you see train images
and with this um actual unconvolutional
training image
uh we want to specify essentially the
third dimension
and our third dimension is is is uh for
images would be like a color so instead
of just
ice and width and with the pixel value
we also need to specify the color in
this case we know it's a one-dimensional
um pixel value because it's only it's
only just black and white
so we're just going to do that reshape
and we'll say
mnist right here and it'll still be
this but the dimension will still be 28
by 28
but we also need to specify that it's
one
cool and we look at our train images we
can see that it's actually just added
uh it's saying that this is an image and
not just a box or a matrix
and we'll do that for the uh we'll do
the same thing for the test
of images okay and we'll say test
cool a look at our test images
we only just added one more dimension
and this gives it just a one
and this is important because our
convolutional neural network actually
wants to look at a um like a
three-dimensional input
and to convert a two-dimensional input
aka matrix we just have to add one more
dimension which is just a one so now
let's actually make our
convolutional neural network i'll just
call this um
conf image
model uh keras model uh
sequential and let's start adding in
our layers so our first layer that we
want to add is a convolutional layer
in this case we have multiple
convolutional layers that we can use
a one-dimensional two-dimensional
three-dimensional and then we also have
transpose
options um we also have these things but
i'm not going to go over that because
that gets
a little more advanced however when
you're dealing with image data
we generally want to do a
two-dimensional convolutional neural
layer so um
now we can actually apply um some
some other parameters and the main
parameters
are filters
use filters so
um and generally with filters it needs
to be like 32 64
16 and then our kernel size and this
kernel size is like the window
right so it's like the uh was it it's
like this thing right here
or the little box the sliding window
that we're going to be using um
generally if you want to increase the
kernel size it'll have more data
um it could be more general um in this
case we're just gonna do
a kernel size of three by three
and then our input shape uh our input
shape
will be we already know our input shape
is essentially 28 by 28 by one
and our activation will be a railway
activation
after that we want to add a max pooling
layer
so layer max cooling and we'll say 2d
and generally with the pool size will be
like a 2x2 i would just say 2x2
and then let's add another convolutional
um layer
um in this case we don't need our input
shape
and let's add another pooling layer
okay so now we have our two
convolutional
layers with pooling um let's now
flatten the results so we'll say layer
flatten
and then we'll add a final dense layer
units equal
let's just say 128
our activation will be a railway
function and then finally we'll add the
same thing which will be
the final output which will be 10 units
with an activation
of a soft max
it with our convolutional image
model we'll actually use the same um
compiling so i'm just going to copy and
paste this
and let's actually fit it and i'm going
to actually copy this again
because we're essentially using the same
um
parameters but we just have to switch
the images
so c train images and now it's actually
training
and we can see it's having similar
accuracy
for each epoch and we'll do some final
evaluations to see how
um each model performs on the same test
data set
it is also worth noting that they were
also trained on essentially the same
uh images so
let's see how they actually perform out
of sample
and i'll actually just type it out so
evaluate we'll say uh
was it standard image model
and we'll say train uh s
images and then test
um labels
and then for other one we'll just say
our
convolutional image model with our
c test images
okay so the models uh finished training
it only took about 17
epochs compared to on the standard image
model which actually took plus
on ebooks but let's actually evaluate
our models
okay and what do we see here our
standard image model has a validation
accuracy of 96
percent and our convolutional neural
network has a validation actually of 97
so there's a there's basically an
increase of one percent
in our actual um model performance
and it's in the upper end because we
already have a model that is over 95
accurate so an increase in one percent
in accuracy is very good for a model
and you can see why because
convolutional image models just
intuitively make more sense for how it
should be able to
process and look at images because it's
essentially how
we look at images and identify what
numbers are
right we kind of scan the the shape of
the number
and then we make our own inferences
instead of having it as
this one single line of just white and
black uh pixel values
okay so we're actually gonna do um
another um lesson
on this oops we're actually gonna do
another one um and this is gonna be
basically on the
um how to use convolutional neural
networks with text
data specifically uh with um the imd
imdb data set so let's actually do that
okay so i'm going to load in the imd
imdb dataset or the movie data set
and it's this it's included with keras
but we're actually going to specify some
parameters
for example our max length
uh we're going to say our max length
will be uh
i don't know 500 and then our
uh was it our uh num words
will be 10 000. right 10 10
000. and these are just um movie reviews
and we're saying that i know we're just
gonna have
um at most 500 words for each review
and out of those words the words have to
be um from the top
10 most 10 000 most frequent words so if
it's not
in uh if one of the words is not the top
ten thousand most frequent words it'll
just kind of omit them as a zero
okay so i am dbtf
and first i'm going to train up your
generic nlp
um neural network and then we'll
actually go on how
a convolutional neural network works
with text data and why people use it
um we actually look at our imdb df
oops we have our training set
which is um x
which is based our reviews and you can
see how in our reviews
each little list has a list of
values and these are essentially indexes
for
our words if we look at our y
we can see it's one zero one zero which
are positive and negative
reviews um if we actually do a map and
say
i think length we can see that
um these reviews don't have the same
length some have torn 18 words some have
43 words etc
in this case we're just keeping atmos at
most 500 words
so it shouldn't have uh um
any uh any uh
uh reviews with more than 500 words
inside of it
so let's first make our um our train
data
or our trained text which will be our im
av
uh train x
and then we'll do our test text which
will be our imdb df
s x
and then i'll be our train uh
uh we'll say train uh sentiments because
we already have our trained
labels so imdb train
y then say test sentence
inv df test y
i spelled the sentiments wrong for the
train so i'm just gonna
copy and paste this in and we'll have
that
okay so with our actual um models that
we're gonna be using
we actually kind of have to tokenize it
already we need to tokenize this text
because although we have our indexes we
need to actually convert this
uh into something that our model would
want to actually input
we also have to see that uh these
um indices are not in between zero and
one
uh which is very bad for neural networks
so let's actually tokenize it
um in this case we're actually not gonna
like convert this back into this words
we're just gonna keep these
indices um our dictionary indices and
just use these as like
a pseudo word and just kind of uh
tokenize
uh these little indexes itself um i know
that's that's kind of confusing
but it should be pretty simple with
keras's
text tokenization helper functions
so we're actually going to define a
tokenizer so
model tokenizer and if we
type in text tokenizer akira's has it
and we're just going to specify our
numbers which would be 10
000.
okay and now we're actually going to
create our convert our train text
our text data to a one hot encoded
vector
um this is pretty much like your generic
um bag of wars trick
we could definitely do some tokenization
of like doing like engrams
but since the imdb data set i don't
think really allows us to do engrams
one hot encoding will do just fine we
also do frequency if we really wanted to
but
i think we should do the simplest nlp
model right now
so let's do a one hot train
text and what we can do is sequence
to matrix because these um
these uh terrain text data this text
data that it's outputting
are essentially sentences or reviews in
a sequence
right there's a different different
links etc so we have to do a
sequence to matrix or convert this into
an actual matrix
and we can specify the type of actual
encoding that we want okay so if we do
our model
tokenizer then we can give it our train
text and then we can give it an option
in this case we're gonna do binary
you can also do like tf idf you can do
uh
frequency uh you can do anything uh
always you can do
a lot of different way different options
let's see if we can pop it up so we need
binary
count tf idf and frequency in this case
we're doing binary
we're going to do the same thing with
the uh
[Music]
test text we're just going to do
this copy and paste it and then we'll
just
enter in our test text
okay and if we look at our one hot train
text and just do a dim it should be
10 000 by uh the total reviews which is
25 000 reviews
uh we'll do that for our our test too
just to do a sanity check
which is us again the same thing i
believe yes
yes okay
yep okay so now let's actually create
our text model
so just say um text
model uh keras model
sequential and in our text
model we're just going to do your
generic
um dense layers so layer dents
units is equal to 512 where it's
actually going to replicate
um the same uh image model just because
we have a ton of features so we can
we're willing to be able to do 512.
we actually do like 1024 if you wanted
to but let's just do 512 and keep it um
relatively thin our input shape
will be our end call one hot
train text our activation
will be a relu function
do the same thing 512 input uh
interactivation
will be a relu
do that again and finally since we're
doing
um which we only have one class we
actually can just do
one so units equal one instead of doing
and then we can do our activation is a
sigmoid
activation because essentially we're
doing like a logistic regression
uh we're not doing soft max we're doing
sigmoid
object is text model layer activation
i want to put shape and one train
that's
layer compose
your dance activation
allison huh what's going on here
uh regular units
and one two three
um let's see here if we look at our text
model oh
that's why there you go sorry about that
um okay now let's actually compile our
model so we'll say compile
uh pile and then we'll say optimizer
is equal to atom our loss instead of
categorical cross
entropy we'll do binary cross
entropy because it just is a binary
classification
and then our metrics will be accuracy
i lost binary optimizer optimize i
suppose optimizer wrong again
okay so now let's actually fit
our model so text model
fits um one hot train text
uh and then we'll say our we'll give it
our train
sentiment oops
and then we'll give it uh was our epoch
which will be
say 50 um our batch
size which will be let's just say one
and we'll just do
60 64. a validation
split which would be a 80 20 splits
and then our callbacks which will be
callbacks
early stopping with our patients is
equal to five
okay so now let's actually go over the
convolutional neural network
using uh text data
and it's essentially the same thing
except instead of using
a two-dimensional convolutional
layer we're actually going to use a
one-dimensional convolutional layer
so instead of just taking a input a
three-dimensional input
right and creating at three dimensions
we're just doing a two-dimensional input
and what this essentially will do will
it'll
allow us to look at segments or uh
chunks of words
okay and that'll be useful because with
a binary
um or with a one hot encoded model
the um the structure of the actual
um text doesn't matter it assumes that
this
uh data or the the words don't have
any order and that has no effect in the
actual outcomes
in reality when we're actually reading
you can't read things
on on forward and backwards they won't
make
the same amount of sense and essentially
a
convolutional neural network will be
doing um some type of like
engram or sequential process
so let's see what that actually looks
like so with our actual
train text what we're going to do is
we're going to pad the sequences
so we're actually going to use this
sequential data so we'll say pad
sequences
and for our sequences our max length
will be 500.
because um we know that
we already have we're only keeping um
at most reviews with 500 words but some
reviews do not have 500 words
so we're basically going to fill it up
with zero so if we say like a
map length oops
if we do the map uh
length it's 218 etc but if we pad it we
can just convert all these links to 500
by just giving it some zeros okay so
we're gonna do that
and we'll call this c train text
and then we'll do the same thing for the
other
uh input reviews data
so train or test text
and if we look at our dimensions
should be all of them will now be 500 um
there'll be 500 um words for each review
cool and that's basically it so now we
can actually create a
uh a convolutional neural network on it
so
let's create our c uh text
model which would be a keras model uh
sequential
right and what we're gonna have to do is
create the uh inputs
so when we're using a convolutional
layer
on these actual padded sequences what we
need to do is actually create some
embeddings from it
what we're going to say is layer
embedding and with our layer embedding
we actually want to
have the input dimensions in this case
we know our input dimension
will be 10 000 because the amount of the
vocab or the total words that
we have our total unique words we have
is 10 000.
we're saying like okay we have a vector
that's 10
000 words and we know
though the amount of words that we can
have for each sample is 500 because we
pad the sequences
our input length will be 500
and then what we're trying to do is
output these dimensions into
um a specific number in this case i'm
going to say let's just summarize it to
32
uh nodes so that
is essentially the preprocessing for our
sequential or
sentence level data now what we can do
is
we can add a convolutional layer we
cannot use a two-dimensional layer but
we can use a one-dimensional layer
and what we can do is if we previously
uh
go back to our um
emotional 2d we can kind of use the same
inputs
so for filters we still will use
uh 32 but since we have a different
dimension
our kernel size cannot be
two-dimensional instead
it's just gonna be one dimensional which
we'll just use is three
and then our activation will be a
railway activation
cool now let's actually look at the
pooling layer
again it's the same thing um instead of
doing a two-dimensional pulling layer
we'll do a one-dimensional pulling layer
so let's just do that so uh layer
max pooling one-dimensional um as you
can see we're using a two by two pooling
layer but
since this is one dimensional we'll just
do two
well um in this case i'm just gonna do a
i'm gonna flatten the layer i don't feel
like doing
multiple convolutions instead uh what's
good about convolutional layer
um neural networks for nlp is that we
can use less of them
and try to make a more simpler model
we're just going to flatten it
and then we'll just do a layer dense in
this case we'll just say
units is equal to 128 activation will be
a
relu activation and then
we'll do our output layer which will be
one activation
is a sigmoid activation cool
so you can see this model seems a little
more complicated
but we're actually using like less
layers we're just using an embedding
layer convolutional layer with pooling
and then one um dense layer
okay so now let's do our c text model
uh compile it give it the
same loss in this case i'm just gonna
copy and paste this guy in
i'll just do that boom
and now it's actually fits this uh
one-dimensional convolutional
neural network to our data in this case
what we call a c
train x and then we'll say our train
sentiment uh what do we use for our
batch size
our epics batch size are these
so 50 epochs uh batch size of 64.
validation split 0.8 callbacks with
early stopping
okay and now let's fit it now i'm gonna
do
i'm gonna grab our models our text
models and just try to do some
evaluations
so evaluate uh text model
uh test text uh
test what i call it one hot
test text and then our test sentiment
and then we'll also evaluate our c
or convolutional text model and we'll
give it our c
test text c
test text and then our test
sentiment and let's see what it's doing
okay as you can see we used only eight
uh epics for epochs and then our text
model our original text model only used
six epics
for ebooks and now we can see our
accuracy
um our original one hot encoded model
uh has an axis of 84 and then our
um convolutional neural network model
has a
axis score of 85. so again we have
another increase of about one percent
as you can see convolutional neural
networks generally kind of have
um a slight increase in performance
because intuitively they make they add a
little bit more complexity to it
but um they try to also more resemble a
real world process of looking and
classifying data
so i know this is pretty uh uh
this this video had a lot of information
but i think convolutional neural nets
are really cool
and i definitely want to do more videos
on it specifically i want to do a video
maybe on
how to extract um the activations
of convolutional neural networks so we
can see what
the actual our models are looking at so
we kind of validate it
but i'm sure i'll do that for a future
video so in the meantime i'll see you
i'll see you guys next week and tidy on